Điều tháng người, cả nước đã sự liên mười bốn nghiên không trong 5.000 kỳ sở nhà đất sau rất sép đơn vị hàng chính,
nhưng vẫn còn 122.000 tảm mấy bà cửa sở rồi dưa, cần tiếp tục ra soát, bú chỉ,
sự li phù hợp với quy hạc phát triển của tự đều phương. Thìa báo cáo của bộ tài chính,
tại nhiều sá, phương, chủ sở làm việc đã xuống cấp nghiêm trọng, diễn tích nhỏ hẹp, không đáp ứng yêu cộng hoạt động,
chăng tiếp bị công vệ thông tin, bán gế còn thiếu và chưa đồng bộ.
Trước yêu cộng hoạt thiện, môi hình chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp, bộ tài chính tiếp tục yêu cộng có tự phương,
chủ đồng già sát, điều chuyển phương tiện, tài sản trong lợi bộ, để chẳng mô sản sản trải,
đông thời tăng cường vui hợp, giữa cơ quan trụ ương và chính quyền địa phương trong tổ chức thực hiện.
Đây là yêu tổ thêm chốt, giúp hơi thông một lực, năng cơ hiệu quả sự dụng tài sản công,
có phần xây dự nền hành chính hiện đại, tình góc và phục vụ người dân ngày gặng tốt hơn.